Now that we have a blank canvas, we can begin inserting SVG elements and
start drawing.
In order for any SVG elements to render on a page,
we first need to insert them into an SVG tag.
Again, let's select the sidebar where the discussion used to be
with the selection.
We can append whatever element we want, in this case an SVG element.
And then with the returned SVG element stored here in an SVG variable,
we can then begin inserting shapes, points, lines, whatever we want.
As you can see, looking at the DOM tree, we have inserted an SVG element.
Hovering over it, Chrome tells us that it's 300 pixels by 150 pixels, but
nothing's actually displayed in the window.
Part of that's because SVG elements by default don't have
any visual representation.
We could change the color of its background.
We could change other properties and attributes defined on it
if we would like to see the bounding box around the SVG.